Intro, I, introductory, N, nice, T, tolerable, R, ramifications, O, O, I, see, uh-oh, this, was the smart less intro. Welcome to smart less. Smart less. Smart less. Smart less. Well, when, when did you, when did you start chasing acting? Huh, great question. Settle in. Couple weeks ago, I think. No, I got a long, I got a long answer. I'm going to give you the long, I mean, it's going to be long. Any kid stuff? Excuse me? Why is that an excuse me? Um, any kid stuff? Uh, I auditioned for a couple of things when I was like 16. I did a couple of commercials. Okay. A tight answer would be great. Yeah, just a tight tighter. So listen, okay. Yeah. Sorry. My answer is sure. You're not the guest. Have you seen the
Intro，我，介绍性的，N，美好的，T，可以忍受的，R，后果，O，O，我明白，呃-哦，这，是这个聪明的简介。欢迎来到SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。嗯，当，你什么时候，你什么时候开始追求演艺事业的？哈，好问题。坐好。大概几周前吧。不，我有一个长，我有一个长答案。我要给你那个长，我的意思是，它会很长。有什么童年趣事吗？不好意思？为什么那是“不好意思”？嗯，有什么童年趣事吗？呃，我大概16岁时试镜过几部作品。拍过几支广告。好吧。一个简短的回答就太好了。是的，就是一个简短，更简短的。所以听着，好吧。是的。抱歉。我的答案是，当然。你又不是嘉宾。你见过
show? Have you seen the show? I think it's on Netflix. It's like, it's the new version of, of, of how they made these movies and they just did aliens. They did like home alone. They did all, do you know what I'm talking about? Yeah. I think I've heard of this, but I don't have the time to watch stuff like this. You have a lot of expend, expendable time. I really enjoy that because I'm a big friend of these movies and they get the cast, they got the Gornie Weaver to chat it. It's really cool about how they made those movies. You know, my feeling on that is there's a lot of behind the scenes and how they made it. It's all like how they made the sausage. Hey, guess what? Just enjoy the sausage. No, I, I enjoy how they make the sausage if I had a dollar.
节目吗？你见过那个节目吗？我想是在Netflix上。就像是，这是他们制作这些电影的新版本，他们刚做了《异形》。他们还做了像《小鬼当家》之类的。他们做了所有，你知道我在说什么吗？是的。我想我听说过这个，但我没有时间看这种东西。你有很多闲，闲暇时间。我真的很喜欢那个，因为我是这些电影的超级粉丝，他们请来了演员，他们找了西格妮·韦弗来聊天。关于他们是怎么拍那些电影的，真的很酷。你知道我对此的感觉是，有很多幕后花絮以及他们是怎么拍的。这就像是怎么做香肠。嘿，你猜怎么着？好好享受香肠就行了。不，我，如果有一块钱的话，我很享受他们是怎么做香肠的。
I know. Um, well, uh, listen, without further ado, uh, let's do, wait, are we, are we in, are we in store for one of Jason's classic, uh, profiles? No, here we go. It's, you're at this in between shows. It's not that great. It's not that great. Um, because the other ones have been, right? Um, I'm talking about my intro, guest, not you. You're going to be incredible. I will give you a quick hint though, you know, talking about how you're not wearing a hat today, Sean. And I love seeing your head. I think you've got a great head. Don't say he's good wears a lot of hats. He does. And I wish that he wouldn't. He's got a beautiful head on him. You'll see right now. Here we go. Okay. So today we have a fellow that has found himself intentionally or not
我知道。嗯，好吧，呃，听着，废话不多说，呃，我们来，等等，我们要，我们要迎来杰森的经典，呃，人物简介之一了吗？不，开始了。这是你在两集之间穿插的。没那么棒。没那么棒。嗯，因为其他的都挺好，对吧？嗯，我说的是我的介绍，嘉宾，不是你。你会表现得不可思议。不过我会给你一个小提示，你知道的，说到你今天没戴帽子，肖恩。我喜欢看你的头。我觉得你的头型很好。别说他挺好，戴很多帽子。他确实戴。我真希望他别戴。他长着一颗漂亮的脑袋。你马上就能看到了。我们开始吧。好吧。所以今天我们来了一位，不管是有意还是无意
as a health analyst and part-time fixer for all that ails us here in our beloved country. Oh, I love it. I love it already. Some may call him a savior. Others may say the opposite, but no matter which side you stand on national policies, you cannot deny that this guy puts the time in on saying what he believes and the consistency of acting on it, leaving us all with a mountain of information that we might not otherwise have the time to research or even initially be interested in knowing. So thank you right up front, sir. He's a one-time Eagle Scout and has since gone on to win an Oscar, a Palm Door and been named one of Time's 100 Most Influential and has now made it to smart less. Congratulations. Mr. Michael Moore. I knew it was Michael Moore.
发现自己成为了我们深爱的国家里所有毛病的健康分析师和兼职解铃人的家伙。哦，我喜欢。我太喜欢了。有人可能会称他为救世主。另一些人可能会说恰恰相反，但无论你站在国家政策的哪一边，你都不能否认这家伙花时间在说出自己的信念以及持之以恒地付诸行动上，给我们留下了海量的信息，否则我们可能没有时间去研究，甚至一开始就对它们感兴趣。所以，先生，首先我要谢谢你。他曾是一名鹰级童子军，后来赢得了奥斯卡奖、金棕榈奖，并被《时代》周刊评为100位最具影响力人物之一，现在他来到了SmartLess。恭喜。迈克尔·摩尔先生。我就知道是迈克尔·摩尔。
Michael Moore. Look at that beautiful hair. You can have the hat there, Sean. I mean, come on. Oh, he does have a hat on. You're wearing a warrior's hat, Michael. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I love some. Dream on green. Michigan State. You followed him all the way there. Michael, I was just in Michigan yesterday. Where you were? Great story, Sean. Yeah, thanks. What were you doing there? A friend of mine lives in Lakeside, Michigan. Was it? Jason, do you know which friend of Sean's lives in Michigan? I was. Dmitri is her name. Reina. It's Reina. That's it. I knew I was close. Well, you know, I'm a big fan of this podcast and I listened to it. No. Yes. I never heard it. I'm your third Michigander on smart less as your guest. Jeff Daniels. Jeff Daniels, right.
迈克尔·摩尔。看看那一头漂亮的头发。你可以在那儿戴上帽子，肖恩。我是说，拜托。哦，他确实戴着帽子。你戴着斯巴达人队的帽子，迈克尔。对。对。对。我喜欢某些。为绿色梦想。密歇根州立大学。你一路追随他到那儿了。迈克尔，我昨天才刚去过密歇根。你去过哪儿？好故事，肖恩。是的，谢谢。你在那里做什么？我的一个朋友住在密歇根州的湖滨。是吗？杰森，你知道肖恩的哪个朋友住在密歇根吗？我是。她叫德米特里。雷娜。是雷娜。就是这样。我知道我猜得很近。好吧，你知道的，我是这个播客的超级粉丝，我也听过。不。是的。我从来没听过。我是你在SmartLess上遇到的第三个密歇根人。杰夫·丹尼尔斯。杰夫·丹尼尔斯，对吧。
On and Ken Burns from Ann Arbor. Oh, yeah. Is that where you started? Yes. No way. So so there's a Michigan thing going on here with a smart list, it seems. Well, listen, we're fond of Michigan. I've got a long history with Michigan. I grew up in Ontario. I'm Michigan adjacent. They said the Canadian. Yes. I'm Michigan adjacent. You know, we used to go, the big, the big foreign vacation for us was to go to a Leafs game, Maple Leafs game in the old garden there. And there was a really cheap hotel right next to the old garden. And we'd all like, we'd get a room, a bunch of guys and we'd just plow in there for the night. The Carlton. Was it the Carlton? The Carlton. That's right. And it, because it's on Carlton Street. It's on Carlton
还有来自安娜堡的肯·伯恩斯。哦，对。那是你开始的地方吗？是的。不会吧。所以，所以这里有一个关于SmartLess的密歇根情结，看起来。好吧，听着，我们对密歇根很有感情。我和密歇根有着很长的渊源。我在安大略长大。我是密歇根的邻居。他们说是加拿大人。是的。我是密歇根的邻居。你知道的，我们过去常去，对我们来说最大的国外假期就是去老花园看一场枫叶队的比赛，多伦多枫叶队的比赛。老花园旁边有一家非常便宜的酒店。我们都会去，一群人开个房间，然后就在那里过夜。卡尔顿酒店。是卡尔顿酒店吗？卡尔顿酒店。没错。而且它，因为它在卡尔顿街上。它在卡尔顿
Street. Yeah. Okay. So, so anyway, so, so yes. And so my grandfather was a Canadian and during the Vietnam War, I was in high school and, you know, myself and my buddies, you know, we were not going to go and kill Vietnamese. What did they do to us? And so that was kind of our thinking. And so we, we did these dry runs because we thought, oh, we're going to get drafted. We're going to have to go to Vietnam. Okay. We're going to have to go to Canada. That's our, that's our plan. So we do these dry runs across the blue water bridge between Port Huron, Michigan and Sarnia, Ontario, just to see what kind of questions will the Canadians ask us if we decide to, to flee or, or, or, or, you know, how, how, what's the Canadian strip search like, which I just said, it's going to be cold, whatever
街上。是的。好吧，所以，不管怎样，所以，所以是的。所以，我祖父是个加拿大人，在越南战争期间，我读高中，你知道的，我和我的死党们，你知道，我们才不去杀越南人呢。他们对我们做什么了？所以这就是我们的想法。因此，我们进行了这些实地彩排，因为我们想，哦，我们要被征兵了。我们得去越南。好吧。我们得去加拿大。那是我们的，那是我们的计划。所以我们在密歇根州休伦港和安大略省萨尼亚之间的蓝水大桥上进行了这些彩排，只是为了看看如果我们决定逃跑，或者，或者，或者，你知道，加拿大人会问我们什么样的问题，加拿大的搜身是什么样的，我刚刚说过，那会很冷，不管
it is, permanently cold hands and they're going to apologize the whole time that they've, that they are doing what they do. So one time we had this idea, what if our escape was a boat and we take a boat across the St. Clair River from Michigan over to Ontario. So one of our, one of our guys here had a boat, his dad had a boat, loaded up the boat on the trailer and we drove over to the, to the river. And you can see candidates, just a quarter mile, half mile, rest of the river. And we go to get the boat off the trailer. There's no motor on the boat. The dude forgot to bring the motor. Now what are we going to do? I said, well, I see you've got oars in here. Yeah, this is just a rowdy fishing boat. Let's, we'll paddle across it. We paddle across
是什么，永远冰冷的手，而且他们在做他们做的事情时，会一路道歉。所以有一次我们有了这个想法，如果我们逃跑的工具是一艘船呢？我们乘船穿过圣克拉尔河，从密歇根到安大略。所以我们这边的某个人有一艘船，他爸爸有一艘船，把船装在拖车上，我们开着车去了河边。你可以看到加拿大，就在河的对岸，四分之一英里，半英里远。我们去把船从拖车上卸下来。船上没有发动机。那家伙忘了把发动机带来。现在我们该怎么办？我说，好吧，我看到你们这里有桨。是的，这只是一艘普通的钓鱼船。我们划过去吧。我们划船穿过
the Canada to see if the Canadians would catch us, which of course we knew. For a soft spot. Yeah. Well, all of Canada's a soft spot. The whole soft border. I'm just saying that. You know, you described Jason on this podcast a little bit. He always shows up with no motor and we're constantly paddling. Jason Bateman, let me just, let me just say, Jason Bateman. And I think it was you, but maybe it was you, Will, but somewhere around 2004, right after bowling for Columbine and Fahrenheit 9-11, I get a call from your producer asking me to be on arrested development, like as a character, but as myself. Right. But they've written me into, do you guys remember this? I feel like I remember this. I feel like I remember
加拿大，看看加拿大人会不会抓住我们，当然我们心知肚明。有个软肋。是的。好吧，整个加拿大都是软肋。整个软肋边界。我只是这么说而已。你知道，你在这个播客上对杰森进行了一点描述。他总是连发动机都不带就出现，而我们一直在划船。杰森·贝特曼，让我，让我说，杰森·贝特曼。我想是你，但也许是你，威尔，大约在2004年，就在《科伦拜恩的Bowling》和《华氏9·11》之后不久，我接到你制片人的电话，让我去客串《发展受阻》，作为一个角色，但扮演我自己。对。但他们把我写进了，你们还记得这个吗？我觉得我记得这个。我觉得我记得
this. Mitch Hurwitz. Mitch Hurwitz, what did you want? Was that who, is that? He was, he's, he's the brain, the creator of the show. Oh, he's the guy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Why do I think it's Jim Burroughs? Jim Vally was his lieutenant. Oh, yeah. So anyways, so they asked me to come and I, I couldn't do it because I love the show so much. It's so smart. And I thought, I'm just going to, I'm going to fail so bad. So I said, I just can't do it. And, and, and, you know, and my agent there, Ari, you know, Ari, and he's like, no, you got to do this. Yeah. And I said, no, it's the smartest show on TV. I know. And it's the smart, it's the smartest one with humans. So the Simpsons would be the, the other one. And, and so on. I wish you'd done it. I wish you'd done it. I didn't do it. And
这个。米奇·赫尔维茨。米奇·赫尔维茨，你想要什么？那是谁，是吗？他，他是，他是这部剧的大脑，创作者。哦，他就是那个人。对。对。对。为什么我以为是吉姆·伯勒斯？吉姆·瓦利是他的副手。哦，对。所以无论如何，他们让我去，但我去不了，因为我太喜欢这部剧了。它太聪明了。我想，我会，我会搞得一团糟。所以我说，我就是做不到。而且，而且，你知道，我那里的经纪人阿里，你知道，阿里，他说，不，你必须这么做。对。我说，不，这是电视上最聪明的剧。我知道。而且它是人类中最聪明的剧。所以《辛普森一家》将是，另一个。然后，等等。我真希望你当时演了。我真希望你演了。我没演，
then so what Mitch did, he hired an actor to play me. Right. And so, do you remember this now? They tried to find somebody that looked like me, but that's impossible. So, so it's, and then I regretted it. I regretted it. And I thought, yeah, you're just, you were just chicken shit about this, and you should have done it. So when you guys came back, when it came back here in the mid-teens, Netflix, Netflix, I, I, I wanted to call one of you and just say, yeah, I'll do it now. How about now? I'll do it now. You know what? When we do it again. Yeah. And you will. Here it comes. We're making news right now, right? Spoiler alert. We're going to do the movie. Is that true? No, come on. Really? Hey, Michael, you mentioned, of course, one of the first times I ever became
然后米奇怎么做的，他雇了一个演员来扮演我。对。所以，你们现在想起来了吗？他们试图找一个长得像我的人，但这不可能。所以，所以，然后我后悔了。我后悔了。我想，是的，你只是，你当时就是个懦夫，你本应该演的。所以当你们回归时，当它在这里十几年代中期回归时，Netflix，Netflix，我，我本想给你们中的一个人打电话，然后说，行吧，我现在演。现在怎么样？我现在演。你知道吗？当我们再次制作的时候。对。而且你会的。它来了。我们现在正在制造新闻，对吧？剧透警告。我们要拍电影了。是真的吗？不，拜托。真的吗？嘿，迈克尔，你提到了，当然，我第一次知道
aware of you in 2004 was the amazing documentary, Bowling for Columbine. Isn't it amazing to think back on that now? And I'm sure you could ask this a lot. Bowling for Columbine. It was just an amazing movie and enlightened us all to, you know, what happens when guns get in the wrong hands. And here we are. I don't know. I can't do the math because I'm too stupid. All these years later. Yeah. And now it's a daily occurrence that there is a mass shooting, a daily occurrence. And we're just so numb to it. And they do. And they define mass shooting as four or more people killed. And it should be more than one. Mass shooting should be more than one. Yeah. But you know, when Americans were like, it's like, you know, this Canadian football, you know, it's not,
你是在2004年，通过那部精彩的纪录片《科伦拜恩的Bowling》。现在回想起来，是不是觉得很神奇？我确信你经常被问到这个问题。《科伦拜恩的Bowling》。这真是一部精彩的电影，让我们所有人都明白了，你知道的，当枪支落入坏人手中时会发生什么。而我们现在在这里。我不知道。我不会算数，因为我太蠢了。这么多年过去了。是的。现在每天都有大规模枪击案发生，每天都有。而我们对此已经麻木了。他们确实如此。他们将大规模枪击案定义为四人或更多人死亡。应该是一人以上。大规模枪击案应该是一人以上。是的。但你知道，当美国人觉得，这就像是，你知道的，这个加拿大橄榄球，你知道，它不是，
you have only three downs. We have four. We have to have more than you. You have to have more. Six points, not one point. Well, that's a good, well, that's a good point. The rest of the world plays football. They get one point when they score a goal. We get six just because we are America. Right. America's what was it like 90% or something is for some kind of gun control. And we still haven't accomplished that. 90% is correct. What is the deal? I don't understand it. What is it going to take? Well, first of all, the NRA is not the force that they used to be. They are not the big scary lobby that Democrats would never want to cross them. That's those days are gone for them. And I think some of these shootings, like in Sandy Hook in Connecticut, where 21st graders
你们只有三次进攻机会。我们有四次。我们必须比你们多。你们必须有更多。六分，而不是一分。嗯，那是个好，嗯，那是个好点子。世界其他地方踢足球。他们进一个球得一分。我们得六分，只因为我们是美国。对。美国大概90%还是多少人支持某种枪支管控？我们还是没有实现。90%是正确的。这到底是怎么回事？我不明白。这到底需要什么？首先，全国步枪协会（NRA）已经不是过去那个势力庞大了。他们不再是让民主党人永远不敢惹的大游行说客了，那些日子对他们来说已经一去不复返了。而且我认为其中一些枪击事件，比如康涅狄格州桑迪胡克小学的枪击案，那里有21个一年级学生
essentially had their heads blown off or their faces blown off. It's unbelievable. And there's so much about things like this. I've actually thought for some time, and I've actually filmed a little bit of an idea I have, because I remember this from the Vietnam War. And again, thank you, Canada, because we watched the CBC in Detroit and Flint. And the CBC, the Canadian Broadcasting, the Nightly News, which was on like a nine o'clock at night, prime time, told the truth about Vietnam, told us Americans across the river, what was really going on with this war. And I remember thinking and talking to my Canadian cousins, why don't you kill the same number of Canadians, each of you, that we do in the United States? Because you're no better than us. You've got the
基本上脑袋被打飞了，或者脸被打飞了。这太难以置信了。关于这种事情有很多。其实我有一段时间一直在想，我也拍了一点我有的想法，因为我从越战中记住了这一点。再次感谢加拿大，因为我们在底特律和弗林特收看CBC（加拿大广播公司）。CBC，加拿大广播公司，晚间新闻，大约在晚上九点黄金时段播出，讲了关于越南的真话，告诉我们河对岸的美国人，这场战争到底是怎么回事。我记得当时在想，并和我的加拿大表亲们交谈，为什么你们加拿大人不像我们在美国那样，每人杀死相同数量的加拿大人呢？因为你们并不比我们好。你们细胞里的23对染色体和我们一模一样。你们看同样的暴力电影和暴力电视节目，所有的原因，他们给出的为什么我们这样做而加拿大人和其他人不这样做的原因。我本来，我本来要在电影里指出这一点，因为我确实去了加拿大，这在《科伦拜恩的Bowling》里有。我们去了位于渥太华的叫什么名字的加拿大统计局，对美国人来说，我必须说，那是首都。事实证明，按人均计算，加拿大家庭中的枪支比美国家庭中还要多，因为在加拿大，狩猎是第一大运动，甚至超过了曲棍球。那为什么加拿大人，他们有这么多枪，为什么他们不互相射击呢？对。好吧，你提出了一个很好的观点，那就是
same 23 chromosomes in yourselves that we do. You watch the same violent movies and violent TV shows, everything, all the reasons they give for why we do it and the Canadians and others don't do it. And I was going to, I was actually going to make this point in the movie, because I did go to Canada, and it's in Boney for Combine. We went to what's it called, Statistics Canada in Ottawa, which for Americans, I have to say, that's the capital. And it turns out, per capita, there are more guns in Canadian homes than in American homes, because hunting is the number one sport in Canada, more so than hockey. So why don't the Canadians, they got all these guns, why don't they shoot each other? Right. Well, you made a great point, which is
几件事。一件事是，在电影里，当你去加拿大，你去别人家里，他们的门都没有锁。我只是走到随机的门前，晚上打开它们。晚上走到别人家里，走进去，人们会说，哦，最近怎么样？你过得怎么样？我知道。然后你说，对不起，我只是走进来了，就像，不，没关系，请进。你饿了吗？是的，怎么了？我们将那个场景，拍摄那个场景，推迟了两年拍摄，作为最后一个要拍的镜头，以防万一某个加拿大人会，因为在美国你不能这样做，你不能就这样走进别人的家里。万一他们开枪打你。万一他们开枪打我，至少我们已经拍完了大部分电影。是的，那个聪明的人，
couple things. One thing is, in the movie, when you go to Canada and you go to people's houses and their doors aren't locked, I just go up to random doors and open them at night. And walk to people's houses at night and walk in and people would go, oh, how's it going? How are you doing? I know. And you go, sorry, I just walked in like, no, that's okay, come on in. Are you hungry? Yeah, what's going on? We put that scene, shooting that scene off, we put that off for two years, so the very last thing to shoot, just in case a Canadian would, because you can't do that in the United States, you just can't walk into somebody's house. Just in case they shoot you. Just in case they shoot me, at least we'd have most of the movie. Yeah, it was that smart guy,
那是很好的制作，顺便说一句，非常好的制作。我总是先把电影放在第一位。但我想说，所以再次，我知道作为一个加拿大人，我曾和其他加拿大人谈过这件事，当我们看到那一幕时，内心充满了自豪感，因为它展示了很多，我认为加拿大人对这种观念感到非常自豪，就像是，是的，我们不是，我们的第一本能不是杀戮。所以这有点回到了几件事。肖恩，你所说的，你说那部电影很棒，因为它是关于枪支落入坏人手中时会发生的事情。我不认为那是对的。我认为这是一个，我热爱这个国家，我在这个国家生活了很多年，我真的很热爱它，
that's good producing, by the way, really good producing. I'm always thinking of the film first. But I want to say, so again, and I know as a Canadian, and I've talked to other Canadians about it, it's a great moment of pride when we watch that scene, because it shows a lot, I think Canadians take a lot of pride in that notion that like, yeah, we're not, our first instinct isn't to kill. And so it goes kind of back to a couple of things. Sean, what you said, you said that movie is great, because it's about what happens when guns get in the wrong hands. I don't think that that's right. I think that it's a, and I love this country, and I've lived in this country for many years now, and I really love it,
这里有很多美好的事物。但这是关于文化的转变。文化需要转变，态度、方法，以及我们如何看待同胞、我们的邻居，把他们看作我们所有人，我们链条最薄弱的一环决定了我们的强大程度。这种观念在这个国家并不存在。就像你说的，人均枪支更多。为什么没有更多的死亡？因为这不是，这是一个文化差异。我认为在下一代中需要发生的事情，希望它会发生，需要发生文化转变。而且这不是，顺便说一句，我们不是一个政治节目，你听过它，我们不以这种方式交谈，我们不，说某人作为一个人赢得了获得医疗保健的权利，能够接触到医疗保健，这并不是政治性的。那他妈的才叫人性。但威尔、威尔、迈克尔或杰森，对于这种说法，你们怎么看：这一切都源于心理健康问题？问题是心理健康，而不是枪支。
and there are a lot of great things about it. But it's about a shift in the culture. There needs to be a shift in the culture, and the attitude, and the approach, and how we look at our fellow, at our neighbors, and look at them as all of us, we're only as strong as our weakest link. And that notion doesn't exist in this country. Like you said, there are more guns per capita. Why aren't there more deaths? Because it's not the, it's, there is a cultural difference. And I think that what needs to happen in the next generation, and hopefully it will, there needs to be a cultural shift. And it's not, and by the way, we're not a political show, you've listened to it, we don't talk in this way, we don't, it's not political to say that
从统计学上讲，这根本说不通。根本不。我是说，是的，很明显，我们需要在这个国家提供心理健康护理，而且它需要是免费的。就像大多数其他发达国家一样。你说的对，威尔。我们必须，我们必须在这里改变文化方面的东西。这不是政治问题。你绝对是对的。我们必须改变。我是说，我，我11岁开始去打猎。在那个时候，11岁和12岁的孩子，
somebody has earned the right as a human being to be treated with healthcare, they have access to healthcare. That's just fucking human. But Will, Will or Michael or Jason, what do you think about this argument though, that it's all based in mental health issues? That's the problem not the gun. It can't statistically, it can't stack up that way. It doesn't. I mean, yes, we obviously, we need mental health care in this country, and it needs to be free. Like it has in most other advanced countries. What you said, Will is correct. We have to, we have to change the cultural thing here. It's not a political thing. You're absolutely right. We have to change. I mean, I, I started going hunting when I was 11 years old. And at that time, 11 and 12 year olds,
他们只是，我们只是去树林里，父母，你知道的，我们只是拿着枪去射野鸡。晚饭见。是的。如果我们，如果我们能活着回来。当然，我们都是，由于是一个天主教社区，所以每个人大约都有11个孩子。所以，你知道，我想我的感觉是，我们长大成人，所有这些有11个孩子的家庭，他们只是在碰运气。你知道，总有一两个会在树林里被枪打中。我们在街上打棒球，等等。但是我的重点，我的重点是，文化，我在童子军时赢得了NRA神枪手奖。你加入NRA是为了渗透它，对吧？而且，而且，我本打算和查尔顿·赫斯顿竞选。我当时是这么想的。所以我是NRA的终身会员。
they're just, we just go out to the woods, the parents, when you know, we just take the guns and go shoot pheasants. See you at dinner. Yeah. If we, if we make it. Of course, we were all, as a Catholic neighborhood, so everybody had like 11 kids. So, you know, I think my feeling was that we're growing up, all these families with 11 kids, it's, they're just playing the odds here. You know, one or two are going to get shot out in the woods. We play baseball out in the street, et cetera. So, but my point, my point is, is that the culture, I won the NRA Marksman award when I was in Boy Scouts. And you joined the NRA to infiltrate it, right? And, and, and, and, I was going to run against Charlton Heston. That was my thought. So I'm a lifetime member
我喜欢那样。直到我被逐出教会。但是，但是你知道，这里，让我告诉你们，肖恩和杰森，关于威尔长大的地方。他们，他们不断让枪支法律变得越来越严格。在加拿大很难买到手枪，对吧？事实上，他们，他们最近增加了一项新法律，如果你想要一把手枪，你必须让你的妻子、你的女朋友、你的前妻、你的前女友。她们必须签署一份表格，证明你精神正常，不是家庭暴力施暴者。所以你需要担保人。是的。但是，由女性来决定男性是否能拥有枪支。这太棒了。所以我开始想，那会是什么样子？如果你在，在安大略省萨德伯里的一个客厅里，
of the NRA. I love that. Until I was excommunicated. But, but you know, there's, here's, let me just tell you guys, Sean and Jason about, you know, where Will grew up. They have, they have, they keep making their gun laws stronger and stronger. It's really hard to get a handgun in Canada, right? And in fact, they've, they've, sometime recently, they've added a new piece of the law, which is if you want a handgun, you have to get your wife, your girlfriend, your ex-wife, your ex-girlfriend. They have to sign a form that says you are mentally okay and not a domestic abuser. So you need sponsors. Yes. But, but the women decide if the men get the gun. That's awesome. So I started thinking, what's that look like? If you're in a, in a, you're in a living
那家伙想买一把枪，他拿着政府表格，不得不把妻子、前妻、女朋友、前女友、情妇都叫到一起。他生命中的任何女性都必须签署这个。他拿着纸说，好吧，现在听着，除非你们所有人都签了这个，否则我买不到枪。她们说，我拥有枪支是可以的。然后她们都说，去你妈的。我们不签这个。他就像，他就像，真的很生气，对吧？他就像，我要告诉你们。如果你们不签，我就杀了你们。是的，对。只要我一拿到枪。是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。那么迈克尔，我是，我想象大多数猎人等，
room in Sudbury, Ontario, and, and the guy wants to get a gun and he's got the government form and he's had to call together the wife, the ex-wife, the girlfriend, the ex-girlfriend, the mistress. Any women in his life have to sign this. And he's got the paper and he's like, okay, now listen, I can't get a gun unless all of you sign this. They say, it's, it's okay for me to have a gun. And they're all like, fuck you. We're not signing this. And he's like, he's like, it's really mad, right? He's like, I'm going to tell you something. If you don't sign this, I'm going to kill you. Yeah, right. As soon as I get a gun. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So Michael is the, I would, I would imagine that most of the hunters, et cetera, are in
实际上，民意调查支持这一点，他们赞成基本类型的枪支管制，枪支审查，不管它叫什么。所以多数共和党人是赞成的。对。而阻止我们对这些进行基本的监管的东西，再次缺乏适当的术语，是因为枪支游说集团。我的，我的问题是，枪支游说集团之所以如此强大、如此庞大、如此重要，是因为枪支制造和枪支销售的实际行业利润如此丰厚，以至于他们想要保护它，在这个国家卖枪真的能赚那么多钱吗？是的。事实上，不幸的是，就在桑迪胡克小学马路对面，就是全美枪支制造商协会的国家总部， literalmente就在康涅狄格州的同一个镇上。不，他们，他们，是的，当然这关乎金钱，但这也是威尔之前提到的别的东西。我们美国人，
effect, the, the, the polls bear this out that they're in favor of, of, of basic sort of gun control, gun review, whatever it's called. So the majority of Republicans are in favor. Right. And the thing that is stopping us from having just sort of these basic sort of regulations over that, again, for lack of the appropriate term, is because of the gun lobby. And my, my question to you is, is the reason the gun lobby is so strong, so big, so important, is it because the actual industry of gun making and gun selling is so lucrative that they want to protect, is there really that much money made selling guns in this country? It's just, Yes. In fact, and sadly, just down the road from the Sandy Hook Elementary School is the
我们在太多时候太害怕人了。我们伴随着恐惧生活，我们的恐惧被操纵了，特别是我们现在看到种族，它们被货币化了。哦，是的，不，那些文件显示，人们越害怕，他们就能赚越多的钱。而这种恐惧涵盖了一切，从一个觉得自己太胖的十几岁女孩，到一个觉得我有太多青春痘的十几岁男孩，再到无论什么。而且，人们不会喜欢我，你开始生活在，你带着这种恐惧生活。恐怖电影也很赚钱。我是说，你知道，不是轻描淡写，但人们，这是这个国家一种非常强烈的情绪。但它，如果人们只是通过看恐怖电影来宣泄这些情绪，其实会好得多。吃爆米花。没错。吃爆米花。但遗憾的是，我认为种族在许多人认为他们家里需要一把枪的原因中发挥了重要作用。而在家里拥有一门枪，你能拥有的最糟糕的东西就是枪，因为统计数据显示，你家里有人用枪自杀的几率，远大于任何其他方式。所有其他试图自杀的方式，过量服用。有个，吉姆·杰弗里斯有一个很棒的段子，
national, it's national headquarters of the Gun Manufacturers Association of America, literally in the same town there in Connecticut. And no, they, they, yes, of course it's about the money, but it's also something else that we'll sort of alluded to. We Americans, we are afraid in people way too much of the time. We live with fear and, and our fears are manipulated, especially we've, we've seen it now where race, they're monetized. Oh yeah, no, those papers showed that they will make more money the more afraid people are. And that fear goes from everything from a teenager feeling that she's too fat to a teenage boy, I've got too many pimples to, to whatever. And, and people won't like me and they start to, you start living your
他是一个澳大利亚的单口喜剧演员，他做了这个段子。我完全无法演绎出它的精髓，但他是在模仿美国人，因为澳大利亚也有很好的枪支管制法。他就像，当美国人在家里买枪并把它们放在保险箱里时，他模仿一个破门而入的家伙说：“等一下，我去拿我的枪。”他模仿组合锁转两下向右，一下向左。等一下。我马上就到。然后，对，你知道，我不理解。迈克尔。是的。你，你开始所有的这些努力时，是不是带着对为无声者发声或将聚光灯投向隐形者的不灭热情？还是说，那是随着你作为一名电影制作人开始起步并发现你制作电影的主题激发了你对比如，鸡生蛋还是蛋生鸡的这种热情，而自然发展出来的？如果你这么说的话，电影会排在第一位，因为我一直坚信，尽管我一直关心这些事情。我是说，在我14岁时，我问父母我是否可以离开家。我受到切萨瓦·查韦斯、贝根兄弟这些，你知道的，这类自由派天主教徒的启发。我想去神学院当神父。我不得不说服他们同意这一点。如果你对天主教父母说，你有一种召唤，就像有人对你说话一样，他们无法阻碍这一点。所以我在九年级时离开家去了一个神学院，
life with this fear. And scary movies make a lot of money too. I mean, you know, not to trivialize it, but people, it is a very big emotion in this country. But it's, and it would be much better actually if people just got those emotions dealt with cathartically by watching horror movies. Eating popcorn. Exactly. And eating popcorn. But unfortunately, I think that race has played a significant role in why a lot of people think they need a gun in the home. And the worst thing you can have is a gun in the home because the statistics show you have a much greater chance of someone in your home committing suicide with a gun than, than any other way. All the other ways of trying to kill yourself overdose. There's a, there's a great bit that Jim Jeffries is a
去学习成为一名神父。因为我关心所有这些社会问题。但是他们一年后把我开除了。然后我走下去，我对最高层，他们有神父，我说，你们为什么开除我？我做了，我遵守了规则。任何，任何叫维基神父的人，他说，因为你问了太多问题。他说，我们是一个答案的机构，而不是问题的机构。而且，顺便说一句，我的意思是，这听起来就像任何担心自己的故事被戳穿的人，你知道我的意思吗？这听起来就像他是棒棒糖窑的成员。哦，哇。所以无论如何，但我热爱电影。我一直，从十几岁起，一拿到驾照，我就开车去安娜堡和底特律看所有的黑泽明、戈达尔、弗朗索瓦·特吕弗，所有的电影。我去看所有的电影。而且，在1983年，我开车去那里看了一部纪录片，对它了解不多。它本应该是关于，你知道的，原子武器或核电的。整部电影都是，也许你看过这部电影，它叫《原子咖啡馆》。里面全是50年代各种恐怖玩意的剪辑。你知道，这很搞笑，但它是关于世界末日的。对。而我，我当时想，哇，你可以拍一部纪录片而且还很搞笑。这就像，谁干过这个？因为我不喜欢纪录片。但所以我也看了很多电影，而且，而且，当我在，如果他们现在让我去电影课上讲话，我总是对他们说，你知道，
standup comic and he's Australian and he does this bit. I'm not going to do it justice at all, but he was imitating an American cause they have great gun control laws in Australia as well. And he's like, when Americans buy guns and keep them in a safe in their home, and he was imitating a guy breaking in and saying, just wait one second while I go grab my gun. And it imitates doing the combination of two to the right, one to the left. Hang on one sec. I'll be right there. And then, right, you know, I don't understand it. Michael. Yeah. Did you, did you start all of this effort with, with such an undying passion for giving a voice to the unheard or putting a spotlight on the unseen? Or did that, was that something that just developed because you started actually
不是搏击俱乐部的第一条规则，而是纪录片的头号规则是不要拍纪录片。对。拍一部电影。对。你知道的，我讨厌“纪录片制作人”这个词。我们不称斯科塞斯为“虚构片制作人”。对。对。库布里克也不是“虚构片制作人”。我们都在拍电影。你可以用虚构来拍，也可以用非虚构或动画来拍。而且，那些，这些电影制作人通常会被现有的剧本所吸引，这些剧本，这些剧本，讲述了一些他们之前就充满热情的事情，或者他们会开发一些他们之前就充满热情的事情。你发现自己是在等待某个特定的政策、主题或问题找上门来，还是你一直在寻找那些可能受益于你将聚光灯投向它们的事情？这是个好问题。
as a filmmaker and you discovered that the subjects you were making films about triggered all of this passion about like, which was the chicken or the egg? If you put it that way, the film would be first because I've always believed, even though I always cared about these things. And I mean, I asked, when I was 14, I asked my parents if I could leave home. I was inspired by Cesar Chavez, the Bergen brothers, these, you know, kind of liberal Catholics. And I wanted to go to the seminary to be a priest. And I had to talk to him into this. And if you tell a Catholic parent, you have a calling like somebody has spoken to you, they can't get in the way of that. So I got to leave home in ninth grade to go to a seminary. And, and it's a study
而我处理这个问题的方式是，对于下一部电影，我问自己一个问题：我害怕拍什么？哪部电影是我不该拍的？我害怕拍它。那只会带来更多麻烦。所以，有没有，有没有什么事你能告诉我们，现在符合这个描述的，你正在制作的？好吧，如果你答应不告诉任何人。不，不，只有我们。只有我们。对。只有我们。对。是的。我会小声说。我就在这里。听着。我，我好像在，我好像在拖延时间。因为我的，我的大脑在说，别，别把这些说出来。随便给个提示。随便给个提示。我们总是可以剪掉的。我们总是可以剪掉的。我们可以剪掉。我们总是可以剪掉的。我们可以剪掉。晚点给我们打电话说剪掉。可能
to be a priest. And I, because I cared about all these social issues. And, but they, they kicked me out after a year. And I, and I went down and I said to the top, they had priests, I said, why are you kicking me out? I've done, I've obeyed the rules. And any, any father to wiki was his name. He goes, because you asked too many questions. And he said, we are an institution of answers, not questions. And, by the way, I mean, that's like, it sounds like anybody who's, who's worried about holes being poked in their story, you know what I mean? It's like, it also sounds like he's a member of the lollipop kiln. Oh, wow. So anyways, but I love the movies. And I always, I always, from a teenager on, as soon as I got a driver's license, I was driving the Ann Arbor in Detroit
你可以剪掉。有点像足球，对吧？有点像足球或乒乓球。有点像，它应该关于足球。我可以拍一部关于那个的非常有趣的电影。我们不想把你架在火上烤。你考虑一下。你考虑一下。你再来找我们。迈克尔，你认为2024年无党派人士赢得大选的时机终于成熟了吗？我认为最好实际上双方，无论是作为共和党人还是民主党人参选的人都应该是独立的。那种模式已经不管用了。就像我们，我们有3.3万万人。两个政党无法代表广泛的光谱。这太荒谬了。针对3.3万万人的政治思想。所以我们，我希望我们有更多议会制的系统，这样他们就能，
to see all the Kurosawa, Godard, Francois Truffaut, everything. I went to see everything. And, and in 1983, I drove down there and I saw a documentary didn't know much about it. It was supposed to be about, you know, atomic weapons or nuclear power. And the whole film was, maybe you've seen this film, it's called Atomic Cafe. It's all clips of all the scare stuff during the 50s. You know, and it was funny, but it was about the end of the world. Right. And I, and I thought, wow, you could make a documentary and be funny. This is like, who's done this? And because I didn't like documentaries. But so I always went to a lot of movies. And, and I always, and I, when I, if they let me talk to a film class now, I always say to them in, you know, the number one rule of
他们可以组建联盟。国会中会有更多人得到代表，人们也会投票。我认为那1亿不投票的人，他们看不到自己被代表。好吧，你知道吗，你知道最神奇的是什么吗，迈克尔，在过去的一年里，我有多少次不得不，我也是这一点的支持者，我不得不向人们解释议会制是如何运作的。首先，令人震惊的是，这个国家有多少人不知道那是怎么运作的。他们甚至，他们甚至不知道这个概念。当他们听到时，他们会说，嗯，听起来挺不错的。是的。我不知道它是怎么运作的。好吧，这是，我们可以谈谈。你查一下。我今晚告诉你。我今晚在晚餐时要讲。但我很喜欢这个想法，
not fight club, but of documentaries is don't make a documentary. Right. Make a movie. Right. You know, I hate this word documentarian. We don't call Scorsese a fictionitarian. Yeah. Yeah. Kubrick is not a fictionitarian. We all make movies. And you can make it with fiction or you can make it with nonfiction or animation. And those, and those filmmakers will usually be drawn to existing scripts that, that, that, that speak to something that they're previously passionate about, or they will develop something that they're previously passionate about. Do you find yourself waiting until a certain policy or subject or issue finds its way to you, or are you constantly on the search for things that might benefit from you putting your light on it? That's a great question.
迈克尔。我喜欢你说的你处理问题的方式。就像你只是想，我害怕拍什么？这真是太有力了，就像肖恩，我知道你，就像你想，我害怕什么，我知道肖恩害怕在第三大道的大字体路口左转。所以他总是，他会绕过去，他向右转，然后他向右再向右，然后他说，是的，在他去之前，他向右转。这是我生活方式的一个隐喻。但它确实是，但它确实是一个很好的方法，如果我们所有人都能回顾一下，我害怕做的事情是什么？什么让我感到不舒服？也许问题的一部分是我们在国内变得太舒服了。我一边靠在办公室椅上说这话，你知道，蜘蛛侠办公室椅。它确实是一个蜘蛛侠椅子。那是我儿子的游戏
And the way I deal with that is I, the next film, I asked myself the question, what am I afraid to make? What's the movie I, I should not make. I'm afraid to make it. It's just going to be more trouble. And so is there, is there something you could tell us now that you're, that fits that description that you're working on? Well, if you promise not to tell anybody. No, no, it's just us. Just us. Right. Just us. Right. Yeah. I'll whisper. I'm right here. Listen to me. I'm like, I'm, I'm trying to stretch for time here. Because my, my, I know my brain is saying, don't, don't not tell these. Just give it a hand. Just give it a hand. We can always cut it. We can always cut it. We can cut it. We can always cut it. We can always cut it. Call us later and say cut. Probably
椅。好吧，我同意这一点。而且我也认为，如果我们能学会对彼此更友善一些，特别是对那些我们不同意的人，我认为那会好得多。为什么会这样，迈克尔？为什么你认为在这个国家存在这样一种观念，即人们不在乎？我不知道我以前是否在节目中说过这个。我曾对爸爸说，你怎么能，多年前，他是一名律师，然后他和他的一个客户合伙做生意，等等，等等。我说，你为什么从来没有搬去美国？你可以赚更多的钱。他说，因为我有义务回馈把我带到这里的系统。哇。他是认真的。而且他，顺便说一句，那是一种，那是加拿大的文化思维。
you can cut it. Something about soccer, isn't it? Something about soccer or table tennis. Something about, it should be about soccer. I have, I can make a really funny film about that. We don't want to put you on the spot. You think about it. You think about it. You come back to us. Michael, do you think it's finally time for an independent to win in 2024? I think it's best if actually both people, people who run either for as a Republican or a Democrat should be independent. That it doesn't work anymore. Like we've, we've got so many, we've got 330 million people. Two political parties cannot represent the broad spectrum. It's absurd. Political thought for 330 million. So we, I wish we had more of a parliamentary system where they could,
是的。而且他不是，他不是英雄。我是说，他是我的，我爱他。他是我的爸爸。他是一个真正善良、正派和公正的人。但是他，那种想法，当我听到那个时，我当时18岁，他说这话时，他是认真的。而且，为什么这种精神在这里不存在？公民对待政府的方式以及政府对于加拿大公民来说可以而且应该扮演的角色，难道没有根本性的区别吗？它更多的是为了帮助你和你在美国的生活。它更多的是某种，我不知道，它不是，它不是那样，或者至少对某些人来说是这样。好吧，这个国家是从一场革命中诞生的。所以从这个角度想想。一直存在着分歧，但是，但是，加拿大人没有这样做。他们没有，
they could form the coalitions. More people would be represented in Congress and people would vote. I think that hundred million that don't vote, they don't see themselves represented. Well, you know what, you know what's amazing, Michael is how many people, how many times in the last year I've had to, I'm also a proponent of that and I've had to explain to people how the parliamentary system works. First of all, it's shocking how many people in this country don't know how that works. And they don't even, they don't even know the concept of it. And when they hear it, they go, well, that sounds pretty good. Yeah. I don't know how it works. Well, it's, we can talk about it. You look it up. I'll tell you tonight. I'm going to do tonight at dinner. But I love this idea,
他们没有反抗英国人。不，当然没有。他们又熬了大约70、80年，在我们革命之后，因为加拿大人知道英国人只会觉得冷，想回家。而这正是1860年前后发生的事情。出现了一个叫加拿大的东西。真的。事实上，我家人当时住在新泽西州。在革命期间，去了加拿大，因为他们是英王的效忠者。但除了与政府的关系之外，美国文化到底是什么？这种心态究竟是什么，阻碍了这个国家拥有那种团结一致的意识，或者思考，或者更善良？为什么，为什么，这种缺失是什么？为什么会存在？你知道吗？
Michael. I love the way you say you approach it. Like you just want to, what am I afraid to make? That is such a powerful, like Sean, I know that you, like you think, what am I, I know Sean's afraid to make a left on the large font from third. So he always, he'll go around, he'll take a right and then he goes a right and a right and then he goes, yeah, before he goes, he makes a right. It's a metaphor of how I live my life. But it is, but it is a great way to, if all of us could kind of look at like, what is the thing that I'm afraid to do? What's the thing that makes me uncomfortable? Maybe part of the problem is we've all become too comfortable in this country. I say as I lean back in my office chair, you know, Spider-Man office chair. It is a spider-man. It's my son's gaming
我是认真的。好吧，部分，部分答案在上一个片段里，那就是我们诞生于暴力中，而你们没有，加拿大人也没有。所以你们组织自己的方式不同。因此，直到今天，当有一飞机难民降落在多伦多时，你们的首相会在那里迎接并与来自叙利亚或其他地方的每一个难民握手。我希望我们也能那样，你知道，我的加拿大祖父，他在美国我的家乡曾是共和党领袖，我记得他会说，我是一个保守派，但保守派意味着你应该节约你的钱。不要花你没有的钱。你应该保护上帝赐予我们的地球。那，那，那必须是那部分
chair. Well, I agree with that. And I think too that if we could learn to be just kinder to each other, especially the ones that we disagree with, I think that would be a much better thing. Why is it Michael? Why do you think in this country there is this notion that people don't care? I don't know if I told this on the show before. I once said to my dad, how can you, years ago, he was a lawyer and then he went into business with one of his clients and et cetera, et cetera. And I said, why did you never move to the States? You could have made way more money. And he said, because I had an obligation to give back to the system that got me here. Wow. And he meant it. And he, by the way, that's a, that is a Canadian cultural thinking.
椅子。嗯，我同意这一点。而且我也认为，如果我们能学会对彼此更友善一些，尤其是对那些与我们意见不合的人，我认为这会好得多。为什么呢，迈克尔？你为什么认为在这个国家有一种人们不在乎的观念？我不知道我以前是否在节目中讲过这个。我曾经对父亲说，你怎么能……多年前，他是一名律师，后来和他的一个客户合伙做生意等等，等等。我对他说，你为什么从来没搬去美国？你可以赚更多的钱。他说，因为我有义务回馈把我带到这里的体制。哇。他是认真的。顺便说一句，这是一种加拿大式的文化思维。
Yeah. And he's not, he's not a hero. I mean, he's my, I love him. He's my dad. He's a really good, decent and just person. But he, that idea, when I heard that, and I was like 18 when he said that, and he meant it. And it's, and that, why does that not exist here? Isn't there a fundamental difference in how the citizenry considers government and what its role could and should be for the citizens in Canada? It's much more of something to help you and your life in America. It's more of sort of, I don't know, it's not, it's not that, or at least to one, to one side. Well, this country was born out of a revolution. So think about it that way. There was always a discourse, but, but, and the Canadians didn't do it. They didn't,
是啊。而且他不是，他不是英雄。我的意思是，他是我的，我爱他。他是我爸爸。他是一个非常好、正派和公正的人。但他，那个想法，当我听到那个时，我大概18岁，他当时就是那个意思。而且，而且那，为什么这里没有那种东西呢？加拿大公民对待政府的方式以及政府对公民应该起到什么作用，难道不存在根本的差异吗？在加拿大，政府更多是用来帮助你生活的东西；而在美国，它更多是一种，我不知道，它不是，它不是那样，或者至少对其中一方来说是这样。好吧，这个国家是通过革命诞生的。所以换个角度想想。一直以来都有讨论，但是，但是，加拿大人并没有这样做。他们没有这样做，
they didn't revolt against the British. No, of course not. They, they waited them out about another probably 70, 80 years after our revolution, because the Canadians knew that British would just get cold and want to go home. And that's exactly what happened by 1860. There was a thing called Canada. It's true. I actually, my family lived in New Jersey back then. And during the revolution went, went to Canada because they were loyalists to the crown. But apart from the relationship to government, what is it about the American cultural? What is it about that mentality that, that holds this country back from that kind of notion of being in this together or thinking of, or being kinder? Why, why does, what is that lapse? Why does that exist? Do you know?
他们没有对英国人起义。不，当然没有。他们，他们又等了大约70、80年，在我们革命之后，因为加拿大人知道英国人会觉得冷，想回家。事实也确实如此，到了1860年左右，出现了一个叫加拿大的东西。真的。实际上，我当时我的家人住在新泽西。在革命期间去了加拿大，因为他们忠于国王。但是除了与政府的关系之外，美国文化到底是什么？这种心态到底是什么，阻碍了这个国家产生那种同甘共苦或互相体谅的想法？为什么，为什么会有这种差距？为什么会这样？你知道吗？
I'm asking for real. Well, it's part of the, was part of the answers in the last bit, which is that we were founded in violence and, and you weren't and the Canadians weren't. And so you, you organized yourselves differently. And, and so to this day, when you have a plain load of refugees landing in Toronto, your prime minister is there to greet and shake the hand of every refugee coming from Syria or wherever. And I wish we were that, you know, my Canadian grandfather, who was Republican leader in my town in the US, I remember him and he would say that I'm a conservative, but a conservative means that you should conserve your money. Don't spend money you don't have. You should conserve the earth that God gave us. That, that, that is a, that has to be that part
我是认真的。好吧，这是刚才部分回答的一部分，那就是我们是在暴力中建立的，而你们不是，加拿大人也不是。所以你们，你们的组织方式不同。因此，直到今天，当有一飞机难民降落在多伦多时，你们的首相会亲自去迎接并与来自叙利亚或任何地方的每一位难民握手。我希望我们也能那样，你知道的，我那曾担任美国我所在的镇共和党领袖的加拿大祖父，我记得他曾说过，我是一个保守派，但保守派意味着你应该节省你的钱。不要花你没有的钱。你应该保护上帝赐予我们的地球。那是，那是，那必须是那部分
of what conservative means. And, and, and, and, and we're going to sit at the table and have dinner together as a family. I mean, just those basic conservative, what he called conservative values. And who would disagree with what I just said, regardless whether you're a Republican or a Democrat or whatever. Yeah. If we could, if we could somehow, and again, I'm, it's sad because we are a nation that was born in genocide and built on the backs of slaves. And it's not that Canada is a perfect place and doesn't have their shameful history with Native people. But, but we somehow never wanted to really apologize or get over it or, or fix it in some way to where the bottom rung of the American ladder is still occupied by Native Americans and Black Americans.
关于什么是保守派的意思。然后，然后，然后，然后，我们作为一家人将围坐在桌旁共进晚餐。我的意思是，仅仅是那些基本的保守派价值观，他所谓的保守派价值观。不管你是共和党人、民主党人还是什么人，谁会不同意我刚才说的话呢？是的。如果我们能够，如果我们能够设法——再次强调，这很令人悲伤，因为我们是一个生于种族灭绝并建立在奴隶脊梁上的国家。这并不是说加拿大是一个完美的地方，对原住民没有过一段可耻的历史。但是，但是我们不知为何从来不想真正道歉、放下过去，或者以某种方式修复它，以至于美国天梯的最底层依然被美洲原住民和非裔美国人占据着。
And that hasn't changed. And until that changes, I, you know, all this thing about critical race theory they're talking about, it's like, I want, don't you want, we want our children, our grandchildren to be taught the truth about how we were formed, how we've behaved so that we don't behave that way anymore so we can be better. You have to question people who don't want to have those conversations why they don't. Right. I, well, I think because, to be honest, a lot of people, a lot of white people are afraid that if we, if we give up too much to our history, our truth of our history, we're going to have to give up some of what we have. And, and they know the demographics too. They know that white people will not be the majority race in the 2040s. That's just 20 years away.
而这一点并没有改变。在改变之前，你知道的，关于他们谈论的批判性种族理论的所有这些事情，这就好像，我希望，难道你不希望吗？我们希望我们的孩子、我们的孙子孙女被灌输真相，了解我们是如何形成的，我们过去是如何表现的，这样我们就不会再那样表现了，从而我们可以变得更好。你必须质疑那些不想进行这些对话的人，问问他们为什么不想。对。我，嗯，我认为是因为，说实话，很多白人，很多白人都害怕，如果我们，如果我们向我们的历史、向我们历史的真相让步太多，我们将不得不放弃我们所拥有的一些东西。而且，而且他们也知道人口结构。他们知道白人在2040年代将不再是多数族裔。那只是20年后的事。
So they're scared. They're scared. And they think just like the white people in South Africa, we're afraid of, if we let Nelson Mandela out of prison, and if Black people in South Africa have rights and they can vote, it's going to be off of our heads. And that did not happen, did it? And it's never really happened because most people who are victims of any kind of this sort of thing, they don't want to respond that way. They actually want to create the world that they wish they could have lived in all these years. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Michael, would you say the glass half full version of looking at our future, perhaps immediate future, immediate future is that the fear that we've been talking about, which is sort of prompting all of
所以他们害怕。他们害怕。他们觉得，就像南非的白人一样，我们害怕，如果我们放纳尔逊·曼德拉出狱，如果南非的黑人拥有权利并且能够投票，这将会压在我们头上。但这并没有发生，不是吗？而且这从来没有真正发生过，因为大多数遭受过任何此类事情的受害者，他们不想那样回应。他们实际上想要创造一个他们希望自己这些年来能够生活在其中的世界。是的。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。迈克尔，你会不会说，看待我们未来的乐观版本，也许是近期未来、近期未来，那就是我们一直在谈论的恐惧，这种恐惧正在挑起所有这些
these bad behaviors, do you think the fear might dissipate once those folks start to feel the benefits of this administration slash policies, legislation, all that stuff? Will the fear start to subside a bit? And some of that love and kindness that you were talking about as, as the, as the medicine will more freely flow from those people that perhaps that's the path towards a lack of sort of maybe getting rid of this tribalism and all being comfortable enough to treat us as all one as we're all in this together? I think that's already in the process of happening. I think, well, that's nice. I was out there campaigning almost two years ago for Bernie on the road with them. Been a friend of his for since, well, his first election in Vermont in 1990. And I can't
这些不良行为，你认为一旦那些人开始感受到这个政府或政策、立法等等带来的好处，这种恐惧可能会消散吗？恐惧会开始稍微消退吗？而你一直在谈论的作为药剂的那种爱和善良，会更自由地从那些人身上流淌出来，也许这就是摆脱这种部落主义、大家都感到足够舒适从而把我们所有人视为一体（因为我们都在这条船上）的途径？我认为这已经在发生了。我想，好吧，那很好。几乎两年前，我在路上为伯尼进行竞选活动，和他们在一起。自1990年他在佛蒙特州的第一次选举以来，我一直是他的朋友。我无法告诉你
tell you how happy I am that Biden is president. Yeah, I have been stunned so many times. And there's not a lot of coverage of a lot of the little things he's done. In a month or two ago, he got rid of all student debt for any disabled Americans. Well, you're a professional messenger. Can you not help them with figuring out a way to get the word out that it's working, that what he's doing? Like the accomplishments so far are insanely good. But the problem is with so many, like Michael has, he's spoken the truth so many times that what they've done is that they've muddied the waters enough so that when he does say, Hey, look, they did, they did, they eliminate debt for all disabled people. They go, Oh, just another Michael Moore. He's looking to cause trouble.
拜登当选总统让我多么高兴。是的，我曾多次感到震惊。而且对他的许多小举动并没有太多的报道。在一两个月前，他为所有残疾美国人免除了所有学生债务。好吧，你是一个专业的传达者。你难道不能帮他们想个办法，把消息传播出去，证明这是行之有效的，证明他正在做的事——比如目前的成就好得有些疯狂？但问题是，对于很多人来说，就像迈克尔一样，他已经说了太多次真相，以至于他们所做的是，他们把水搅得足够浑，所以当他说，嘿，看，他们确实消除了所有残疾人的债务时，他们会说，哦，又是一个迈克尔·摩尔。他想找麻烦。
It's like, no, no, no, no, no, he's right. Am I right about that? Only with 20% of the population, the people that are on the far right, the people that don't believe the coronavirus is real or the vaccine is, you know, I don't know if we can help that that far 20%. But, but I, I have a lot of success and I have, I have a lot of fans and people that go to my movies and read my books and listen to my podcast, substack, tell us about substack. Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah. No, I have a Sunday letter that I send out for free to anybody who wants it. And, and I talk about these things and I talk about them in a way where I think that I'm not trying to poke people in the eye with it. I'm just trying to say, Hey, if you have a disabled member in your family, aren't you happy that this
就像，不，不，不，不，不，他是对的。我说的对吗？只有20%的人口会这样，那些极右翼的人，那些不相信新冠病毒是真实的或是疫苗是……你知道的，我不知道我们是否能帮到那极端的20%。但是，但是，我有很多成功，我有很多粉丝，人们去看我的电影，读我的书，听我的播客，Substack，跟我们讲讲Substack吧。是的。是的。好吧，是的。不，我有一封周日信件，免费发送给任何想要的人。而且，而且我谈论这些事情，我以一种我认为不是在试图用它戳别人眼睛的方式谈论它们。我只是想说，嘿，如果你的家里有一个残疾成员，难道你不高兴这个
president, a president that I didn't vote for in the primary, aren't you happy that that individual in your family, their student debt has been, has been retired? Isn't that a great thing? It's a little thing, but he's done so many of these little things that I am. So now when you look at the polls, you see that's why there is not a single thing in his infrastructure, the human infrastructure bill that the majority of Americans disagree with. It's, it's 60, 70, 80% in agreement. Michael, how did they do? What, what was the great trick that they played? Sorry to belabor this, but where they took people, you know, let's say you go to Michigan, some person who lives in Michigan, who works, who's been a union member for a long time. It seems like a lot of
总统——一个我在初选中没有投票支持的总统——难道你不高兴你家里的那个成员，他们的学生债务已经被免除了吗？这不是一件好事吗？这是一件小事，但他做了这么多这样的小事，我……所以现在当你看看民意调查时，你会发现这就是为什么在他的基础设施中，在那个绝大多数美国人都赞同的人类基础设施法案中，没有单一的事情是遭到反对的。赞同率达到了60%、70%、80%。迈克尔，他们是怎么做到的？他们玩了什么绝妙的把戏？抱歉纠缠这个，但他们把人——比如说你去密歇根州，某个住在密歇根州的人，他工作，长期以来一直是工会成员。似乎有很多人
these sort of working class people who, who have been part of unions, who have benefited from certain social benefits have been radicalized by the right. That seems to be like a growing contingent of people who, who would benefit a lot from a lot of these things like you're saying, like they might have a family member who would benefit from what Biden's doing and they're benefit from all these things. I'll tell you why, because the Democrats have taken way too long to make these things happen. If they had, if they had made more of it happen sooner, that we wouldn't probably even be in the situation. You're right. They are horrible at their messaging and I would volunteer the next two years of my life to help them with that, if they wanted that
这种工薪阶层，那些曾是工会成员、从某些社会福利中受益的人，被右翼激进化了。这似乎是一个不断增长的人群，他们本来会从很多像你所说的事情中受益匪浅——比如他们可能有一个家庭成员会从拜登正在做的事情中受益，而且他们也从所有这些事情中受益。我来告诉你为什么，因为民主党人花的时间太长了，才让这些事情发生。如果他们能早点让更多的事情实现，我们可能甚至都不会陷入这种境地。你是对的。他们的信息传达太糟糕了，如果他们想要这种帮助，我愿意用我生命中的接下来的两年时间来帮助他们
help. But, you know, I, I mean, I tried that, you know, a couple of years ago, my last movie, I tried to convince Steve Bannon to be in the movie because I wanted him and I to have a sit down talk. Yeah. And, and he told me during this, I didn't, I didn't end up not being in the film, but he said, you know, I was at your very first screening of your very first film in 1989, Roger and me in Telluride, Telluride Film Festival. Yeah. And I sat just down the row from Roger Ebert and I could not believe this film. And I walked out on the street looking for a pay phone, there were no cell phones back then. I called, I called one of our, you know, right wing operatives in DC saying, oh my God, we, the revolution will not be led by us. I've
但是，你知道，我的意思是，我尝试过了，你知道，几年前，我的上一部电影，我试图说服史蒂夫·班农出演这部电影，因为我想让他和我坐下来谈一谈。是的。而且，他在这次谈话中告诉我——我最终没有出现在电影中，但他对我说，你知道，1989年我在特柳赖德电影节上观看了你的第一部电影《罗杰与我》的首次放映。是的。我坐在罗杰·艾伯特座位后面的那一排，我简直不敢相信这部电影。我走到街上寻找公用电话，那时候还没有手机。我打电话给我们在华盛顿的一个，你知道，右翼特工，说：哦，天哪，我们，革命将不会由我们领导。我
just seen this film and this guy that we've never heard of. If, oh my God, he's a problem, he's a problem because, because our people are going to listen to him because he's coming from where they're at. Yeah. And, and he said to me then, this is just two years ago, he said, and, and my greatest thank you to the Democrats is that for these past 30 years, they chose not to listen to you, the democratic leadership, the people that run the party. They've kept you as far away as they can because you are the real threat to them. Yeah. Not to, not to us as much, but to them because, and I was like, well, I was just like listening to this and my head was just spinning and I'm like, you know, and I know this already because you won't see me speaking at the
刚刚看了这部电影，还有这个我们从未听说过的人。如果，哦，天哪，他是个麻烦，他是个麻烦，因为，因为我们的人会听他的，因为他代表着他们的立场。是的。而且，他对我说——这只是两年前的事——他说，我对民主党最大的感谢是，在过去的这30年里，他们选择不听你的话，不听民主党领导层、管理党派的人的话。他们尽其所能让你远离他们，因为你是他们真正的威胁。是的。对我们没那么大威胁，但对他们是，因为，我就像，我当时只是听着，脑子飞速运转，我想，你知道，而且我早就知道了，因为你看不到我在
democratic convention. No, you won't. And why is that? What, what, what was his point? Why are you a threat to the mainstream base of the democratic party? Is that what he's talking about? Yeah. Yes. What, what, what, what would be a threat? Because you're seeing, you're seeing as the extreme left, right? In their eyes. Yes. But there's now not any longer. The majority of Americans believe women should be paid the same as men. Yeah. What I believed 30 or 40 years ago, the majority of Americans, I'm in the middle now, the majority of Americans, the majority of Americans believe the climate is real. Right. I don't have to convince people of these things anymore or, or that minimum wage should not be
民主党大会上发言。不，你不会。为什么会这样？有什么，他的重点是什么？为什么你是民主党主流基础的威胁？他是在说这个吗？是的。是什么，什么，会构成威胁？因为你被视为极左派，对吧？在他们眼里。是的。但这现在已经不再是了。绝大多数美国人认为女性应该获得与男性同工同酬的待遇。是的。30或40年前我所相信的，绝大多数美国人——我现在处于中间立场——绝大多数美国人，绝大多数美国人相信气候变化是真实的。对。我不再需要说服人们相信这些事情，或者说最低工资不应该是
$7 and 25 cents an hour. The American public has come to, to my, we just need to get them to vote. Right. Yes. That's my point. The hundred million. How do we get them to vote? My proposal is to the Democrats get ballot proposals on the ballot that will bring out people who otherwise wouldn't vote. There should be marijuana legalization on every ballot in the, in the, in the country. There, there should, in Michigan, uh, in the last election, we passed a ballot proposal making it a crime to gerrymander or to voter suppress. I think you said crime to have seeds in your, in your weed. Cause that would be, that should be in there too. Cause yeah, fuck that stems and stuff. And you're like, dude, are you fucking, and now he's already left.
每小时7美元25美分。美国公众已经达到了，来到了我的立场，我们只需要让他们去投票。对。是的。这就是我的重点。那一亿人。我们如何让他们去投票？我的建议是给民主党提出将选票提案列入选票，这将吸引那些平时不会投票的人。全国每一张选票上都应该有大麻合法化。在密歇根州，在上一次选举中，我们通过了一项选票提案，将划定不公选区或压制选民的行为定为犯罪。我想你说的是把种子留在你的大麻里是犯罪。因为那也应该在里面，因为，是的，去他的那些茎之类的。而你会觉得，老兄，你他妈的……而他现在已经离开了。
Just sit it out. The marijuana crime I'm mostly concerned about is that when I was a teenager, it smelled so sweet. Yeah. And now it smells like a skunk. What the hell happened here? I don't know. But, but I'm just saying that if, if we get ballot proposals that will bring people out, uh, you know, we don't have an equal rights amendment still in this country. If you had an equal rights amendment for your state on your state ballot, saying women are to be treated equally. Again, you're now appealing to the base of the Democratic Party. Women, young people, people who decides what's on the ballot, would it be the governor of each state? No, no, you just go and get the signatures. How many, how many signatures on
放着不管吧。我最关心的大麻犯罪是，当我还是个青少年时，它闻起来那么甜。是的。而现在它闻起来像个臭鼬。这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。但是，但是我想说的是，如果我们获得能够吸引人们出来的选票提案，你知道，在这个国家我们仍然没有平等权利修正案。如果你的州在州选票上有一项平等权利修正案，规定女性应受到平等的对待。再次强调，你现在是在迎合民主党的基础。女性、年轻人、决定选票内容的人会是每个州的州长吗？不，不，你只需去收集签名。多少，多少签名在
the state? Sometimes it's, it's, it's 50,000. Oh, really? Yeah. If you, if you said, hey, I have an idea for a thing, you can, you could write it up today and you go out. If you get 250,000, that's how, how do you think they did the recall to try to do the recall and Gavin Newsom, it was all based on. Exactly. So it doesn't matter what it is. If I want to make, if I want to make milk green from now on in California, if I get 100,000 votes. The majority of America's on the milk green. Dude, we're not doing it. It could be so much better. But let me just say that I, I wanted to say this at the beginning and, um, the three of you who, um, I've only met you, Sean, I believe, before, um, I, I, uh, Will was in a Flint, the only movie ever set in Flint, uh,
州里？有时是，是，是5万个。哦，真的吗？是的。如果你，如果你说，嘿，我对一件事有个想法，你今天就可以把它写下来然后出去。如果你收集到25万个，你觉得他们是怎么对加文·纽森发起罢免的？完全是基于这个。所以不管是什么。如果我想从现在开始在加利福尼亚把牛奶变成绿色的，如果我能收集到10万张选票。大多数美国人都支持绿色的牛奶。老兄，我们不这么做。它可以变得好得多。但请允许我说，我，我本想在一开始就这么说，而且，嗯，你们三个，嗯，我想我以前只见过你，肖恩，嗯，威尔曾出演过《弗林特》，唯一一部在弗林特拍摄的电影，
fiction film, uh, called semi pro. Yeah. And, uh, the Flint tropics are the basketball team in it. And, uh, and then the, and then my, my chickening out on being on the rest of development, but I just want to say that, um, the more of the three of you in this country, the better, because we need, well, first of all, we all need a good laugh right now. We've gone, we've gone, we're not out of the woods yet. Um, but your ability to use satire and, and to, and to your comedy is so smart. Um, it's just, it's, uh, I can't get enough of it. And, um, you know, I hope someday we can work together in some way because it's, uh, an honor to be on this podcast, uh, you're a nice fellow. It's an honor for you to be on this show. Yeah. Um, yeah. It really is.
虚构电影，名叫《半职业选手》。是的。然后，嗯，弗林特热带队是其中的篮球队。然后，然后，然后是我临阵退缩，没有出演《发展受阻》的剩余部分，但我只想说，嗯，这个国家你们三个越多越好，因为我们需要，首先，我们现在都需要开怀大笑。我们已经经历了，我们已经经历了，我们还没脱离危险。嗯，但是你们运用讽刺和，以及，你们的喜剧的能力太聪明了。嗯，这简直是，嗯，我怎么看都看不够。而且，嗯，你知道，我希望有一天我们能以某种方式合作，因为，嗯，能参加这个播客是我的荣幸，嗯，你是个好人。你能来这个节目是你的荣幸。是的。嗯。确实如此。
It was so much. Mike, I honestly, I remember what Roger and me was, was, was such a milestone in filmmaking. It really was. I remember just being, I couldn't believe it when I saw it, Fahrenheit, uh, uh, 9-11, just incredible. I remember the night I watched, I remember going for dinner afterwards, uh, with my accent, a good friend of ours and talking about it. We were so moved, uh, bowling for Columbine. Um, you know, all these things, I, you're, you're, look, man, you're, you're such a brave, brave soul. You really are. And, and I love the idea. And again, it goes with, I need to say it again, if you're listening to this podcast and you think that these are just a bunch of, you know, that we're being political, it's not political to talk about
太多了。迈克，老实说，我记得《罗杰与我》是电影制作中的一个里程碑。真的是这样。我记得当我看到它时简直不敢相信，《华氏9·11》，简直不可思议。我还记得我观看的那天晚上，记得后来和我们的一个好朋友去吃晚餐，谈论它。我们太感动了，《科伦拜恩的保龄球》。嗯，你知道，所有这些，你，你，看，伙计，你是一个多么勇敢、勇敢的灵魂。你真的是。而且，我喜欢这个想法。再次强调，这符合——我需要再说一遍，如果你正在听这个播客，并且认为这只是一群，你知道的，我们在搞政治，谈论人类权利可不是政治
human rights. It's just not, uh, and we're just talking about what I love is you come up, your approach of it is, hey, call me, paint me with that, whatever fucking brush you want to paint me with, but let's just get this shit done. Let's get it done. Come on, we're better than this. Yeah, we're better than this. Yeah. Come on, everybody. And I, and I, and I would just like to say thank you for basically saving a lot of us, a lot of work. Whether you agree with you or not agree with you, um, you are providing, as I said in the intro, all of us with a lot of information that we wouldn't otherwise either have the time to research ourselves or be interested in even knowing before we hear it, but you are presenting it to us in, in an incredibly well done way,
根本不是。而且我们只是在谈论——我喜欢的是你的方式，你的方法是：嘿，打电话给我，用任何你妈的刷子给我抹黑，但让我们把这破事干成吧。让我们把它干成。拜托，我们比这更好。是的，我们比这更好。是的。拜托，大家。而且，我，我，我只想说谢谢你，基本上为我们很多人省去了很多工作。无论你同意你还是不同意你，嗯，正如我在开场所说的那样，你为我们所有人提供了大量的信息，否则我们自己既没有时间去研究，甚至在听到之前也没有兴趣知道，但你以一种令人难以置信的出色方式把它呈献给我们，
whether, even, even when you're on talk shows, on news shows, I mean, I just, I love listening to you talk. So please, please keep it going, keep it coming and know that it is fully appreciated as well as entertaining. So. Dido here for everything Jason just said. It just, uh, thank you for everything you've done. Thank you. And keep, keep, please don't stop doing it. Yeah. I, I, I will not stop and, and you don't stop either. No, no, the importance of humor, uh, in our time will, uh, it's, it's, sorry, it's critical. And, um, we tell them, we try to tell them every time. Listen, anybody, anybody that's been in, it was in the Lego movie, uh, one of the, one of the great, no, seriously, one of the great films of all time, one of the most, most, most, um, pointed and, and
无论是，甚至当你出现在脱口秀、新闻节目中时——我的意思是，我就是喜欢听你说话。所以请，请继续保持，源源不断地送上，并且要知道这得到了充分的欣赏，同时也极具娱乐性。所以。对于杰森刚刚所说的一切，我完全赞同。这只是，嗯，谢谢你所做的一切。谢谢。并且保持，请不要停止这样做。是的。我，我，我不会停止，而且你们也不要停下。不，不，幽默的重要性，嗯，在我们的时代，将会，嗯，它是——抱歉——是至关重要的。而且，嗯，我们告诉他们，我们每次都设法告诉他们。听着，任何人，任何曾经参与过《乐高大电影》的人，那是，历史上最伟大的电影之一，最伟大、最尖锐、最
fulfilling, uh, examination of us as a society in the Lego movie. I'm serious. You guys know, I'm telling the, let's, you know, I agree. I agree. Those guys are sneaky smart. Yeah. You know, and, and, and, and, you know, I don't need to go through the whole damn list, but, you know, Ozark, enough said, uh, I mean, just, it's, uh, don't even put it on the list. Don't even put it on, if you don't want to go through the list, just leave it off the list. And you know, we, the public, don't want you to stop doing any of this. We want you to do this work even long after you've, like, I've done this for five years. I'm out. But, um, but the importance of this and of people being able to have that laugh and to have that, I think, you know, if anybody, if you haven't seen the film
令人满足的，关于我们作为一个社会的审视之一，就在《乐高大电影》里。我是认真的。你们知道的，我说的，让我们，你知道，我同意。我同意。那些家伙偷偷摸摸地聪明。是的。你知道，而且，而且，而且，你知道，我不需要把整个该死的名单都念一遍，但，你知道，《黑钱胜罪》，点到为止。我的意思是，简直是，别把它放进名单里。甚至不要把它放进，如果你不想过一遍名单，那就把它排除在名单之外。而且你知道，我们公众，不希望你停止做所有这些事情。我们希望你继续做这项工作，甚至在你像这样——我已经做了五年了。我退出了。但是，但是这项工作的重要性，以及人们能够开怀大笑并拥有那个，我想，你知道，如果任何人，如果你还没看过这部电影
Sullivan's Travels from the 30s, early 40s, about a Hollywood director wanted to make the socially conscious film and get people to think about things. And at the end of the film, he learns the best thing I can do is just to make a great movie and give people a chance to laugh. They've worked hard all week. Life is, life is one curveball after another being thrown at our heads. If what you give people are two solid hours of a great movie and, and one that, where they can laugh and one that treats them as if they're smart, not stupid. That's what all of you, all of you do that. I remember my parents in their 80s were like, Seinfeld was their favorite show. And I'm like, do you guys get any of this upper west side humor? And no, we just think it's funny.
30年代到40年代初的《沙利文游记》，讲的是一个好莱坞导演想要拍一部具有社会意识的电影，让人们思考各种事情。而在电影结束时，他学到的是：我能做的最好的事情就是拍一部好电影，让人们有机会欢笑。他们一星期辛苦工作下来。生活是，生活是一个接一个朝我们脑袋砸来的曲线球。如果你给人们提供整整两个小时的好电影，并且是一部能让他们开怀大笑的电影，一部把他们当成聪明人而不是傻瓜来对待的电影。这就是你们所有人的所作所为，你们所有人都在这样做。我记得我80多岁的父母就像是，宋飞正传是他们最喜欢的节目。而我在想，你们俩能看懂这些上西区的幽默吗？不，我们只是觉得它很好笑。
And I thought, wow, that was the genius of Seinfeld, that he could take a cultural thing, living on the upper west side, and, and people in Flint, Michigan loved it. And, and that's the key. It's what I, again, to the people want to make a documentary, make a movie, not a documentary, make something that people are going to be just, it's going to move them. They're going to have a great laugh. They're going to learn something. They're going to get angry, whatever it is. Don't go for the mediocre. There's a great Kurt Vonnegut line in his only play that he wrote, Happy Birthday, Wanda June. And he says, one of the characters says, you know, in America, they love the mediocre. And boy, I just hated hearing that at the time. That's why we're here.
我想，哇，这就是《宋飞正传》的天才之处，他能把一种文化现象——生活在曼哈顿上西区——而密歇根州弗林特的人们却对它爱不释手。这就是关键。这也是我所说的——再次对那些想拍纪录片的人说，拍电影，而不是纪录片，拍一些能让人们感动的东西。他们会开怀大笑。他们会学到东西。他们会感到生气，无论是什么。不要追求平庸。库尔特·冯内古特在他写过唯一的一部戏剧《生日快乐，万达·琼》中有一句绝妙的台词。他说，其中一个角色说，你知道，在美国，他们热爱平庸。天哪，我当时听到这句话时真是恨透了。这就是我们来这里的原因。
Right. I thought, yes. And, and so we, we, all of us must not do mediocre work. And we must give people a chance while they're coming up out of their seats, feeling like, yes, yes. Dude, Michael, that is so inspiring. I, it's almost like I want it like Jason, can you make a pledge today that you won't make any more mediocre work? Can you think you can actually make that? No, we should have a petition. We should just have something to sign. I'm dancing as fast as I can. When I open, when I open my movie theater, I restored an old movie theater and where I lived in Northern Michigan. And, and one of the first movies we played was Juno. That is an example of a genius film and your role in that was beautiful. It's great. He's a lonely guy. Yeah. It's great. He was, you were,
对。我想，是的。所以我们，我们所有人绝不能做平庸的工作。我们必须给人们一个机会，当他们从座位上站起来时，感觉像：是的，是的。老兄，迈克尔，这太鼓舞人心了。我，这简直就像我想要像——杰森，你今天能做一个承诺，保证不再做任何平庸的工作吗？你觉得你真的能做到吗？不，我们应该发起一个请愿。我们应该弄点东西来签名。我正以最快的速度跳舞。当我开办，当我开办我的电影院时，我修复了一家老电影院，就在我居住的密歇根州北部。而且，而且我们放映的第一批电影之一就是《朱诺》。那是天才电影的一个例子，你在其中的角色非常棒。太棒了。他是个孤独的家伙。是的。太棒了。他是，你是，
you were fantastic. He was great. I forgot about that. You were great. I know. I know. He's always great. These guys, you're, I'm lucky to be with these guys. And the heart that he had with this teenager who was pregnant and, and trying to be a good adult for her was, it was very moving, but of course, but the film is also funny and genius and everything else. I'm just, this is the first thing I popped in my head though, but Jason, your long list of this is, is much appreciated by those of us who do need that respite, that, that, that chance. Well, you're describing beautifully the stuff that you do, making the, making the medicine go down easy by creating some real legitimate entertainment around some education. So please, please keep
你太棒了。他太棒了。我把这事给忘了。你太棒了。我知道。我知道。他总是很棒。这些家伙，你，我很幸运能和这些家伙在一起。他对这个怀孕的、试图为她做一个好成人的少年的那种关怀，非常感人，但当然，这部电影也非常搞笑、极具天才以及其他一切。我只是，这是我脑子里冒出的第一件事，不过杰森，你长长的这个名单，对于我们这些真正需要那种喘息、那种机会的人来说，是非常感激的。好吧，你非常完美地描述了你所做的事情，通过围绕一些教育内容创造一些真正合法的娱乐，让药更容易吞咽。所以请，请继续
that going. And, and, and your stuff is funny as hell as well. I mean, no kidding. Getting the audience to a happy place is always the greatest first step towards change. So I think what, what you're saying there about, you know, channeling the comedy and, you know, Adam McKay is doing a great job with that too, with all the stuff that he's making. And so thank you note, note taken and, and right back at you. He's so jarringly funny. How like Roger and me were so jarringly funny at the time. Not no, I didn't know anything about you before Roger and me. It was, it was so jarringly funny. And yeah, anyway, yeah, thank you, man. Thanks Michael. Thanks for, thanks for hanging out with us on a Saturday. Yeah, we appreciate it. Yeah. It's been, it's been great and an honor.
保持下去。而且，而且，而且你们的东西也搞笑得要命。我是说，不开玩笑。让观众进入一个快乐的境地，永远是迈向改变最伟大的第一步。所以我认为你刚才说的那些，你知道的，引导喜剧，你知道，亚当·麦凯通过他制作的所有作品也在那方面做得非常出色。所以，谢谢你，意见已收到，原封不动地奉还给你。他是那么滑稽地搞笑。就像《罗杰与我》当年是多么滑稽地搞笑一样。不，不，在《罗杰与我》之前我对你一无所知。它是那么滑稽地搞笑。而且，是的，不管怎样，谢谢你，伙计。谢谢迈克尔。谢谢你，谢谢你抽出周六时间和我们在一起。是的，我们很感激。是的。这真的很棒，也是一种荣幸。
And, and we all have a lot, a lot to do. And for the people listening to this, do not give up. That's exactly what they want. Do not give up. Absolutely. Yeah. However, unless you think there's no way it's going to happen, then you do give up. I just want to, I want to give them the out. You basically get your boat in the river up there and start moving your horse towards Canada. If you actually believe that there's no way it's going to get better, get in that boat and go to Canada. Yeah. With no engine. Thank you, Michael. Very, very, very much. Thanks guys. Thanks so much. Be well. Thank you. See you later. That man. I, I, that was super, super exciting to see his face pop up there. Yeah. It was. He's a great filmmaker and a great voice. And I do love, again,
而且，而且我们大家都有很多，很多事情要做。对于听这个的听众，千万不要放弃。这正是他们想要的。千万不要放弃。绝对的。是的。然而，除非你认为绝对不可能实现，那你才放弃。我只是想，我想给他们一个退路。你基本上是在那里把你的船划进河里，然后开始把你的马朝加拿大方向移动。如果你真的相信事情绝无变好的可能，那就上那条小船去加拿大吧。是的。没有发动机。非常、非常、非常感谢你，迈克尔。谢谢你们，伙计们。非常感谢。保重。谢谢。再见。那个人。我，我，看到他的脸突然弹出来，超级、超级激动。是的，确实如此。他是一位伟大的电影制作人和一个伟大的声音。而且我确实喜欢，再次，
I love what a voice he is to try to be a voice of reason and the way that he tries to break issues down that are complicated, that are hot button issues, gun control for whatever reason is a hot button issue. And by the way, it should be fairly cut and dry. And for whatever reason, it's like, yeah, it's like, it's like, for me, I consider it as issues for dummies. Well, just singular, not even, not even plural, just issue for dummy. Dummy. He's, he's, he's presenting it. He's wrapping it in a very relatable, you know, surround. He's, he's just, he knows what he's doing, but he's, but the rap has a sexy indifference too. So it's like a sexy, indifferent rap. I'm like telling you stuff, but I'm not telling you stuff. Yeah,
我喜欢他那样的声音，他试图成为理性的声音，他试图把复杂的问题——那些热门话题——剖析开来。枪支管制无论出于什么原因是一个热门话题。顺便说一句，这本应该相当明确。但出于某种原因，这就好像，是的，这就好像，对我来说，我把它视为“给笨蛋准备的问题”。好吧，只是单数，甚至不是复数，只是“笨蛋的问题”。笨蛋。他，他，他正在提出它。他把它包裹在一个非常容易引起共鸣的，你知道，包围圈里。他，他只是，他知道自己在做什么，但他的外壳也有一种性感的冷漠。所以这就像一个性感的、冷漠的外壳。我就像是告诉你一些事，但我又没有告诉你。是的，
it's kind of a coy. It is, it is a nice, again, whether you agree or not with, with his stuff. I think it's undeniable that what he's doing is somewhat philanthropic because I'm sure he's not, he's not getting, he's not getting super rich off all this stuff. But you know what's great about, about that is he, he doesn't pick a side and we've used this before, but he doesn't pick a side. He's pretty much, by partisan, by partisan. What do you think? Here's what's astounding about your, we've used bipartisan before, by the way. So that's what I said. I said we used it before. Pretty lame dismount. Pretty lame dismount. We'll make it up to you on the next podcast episode. Listener. Oh, thank God you just saved it. You just saved it. You fucking dick. Please
这有点害羞。这确实是一个不错的，再次强调，无论你是否同意他的东西。我认为不可否认的是，他在做的事有点像慈善，因为我确信他没有，他没有靠所有这些东西发大财。但你知道关于那点最棒的是什么吗，他，他没有选边站队——我们以前用过这个词——但他没有选边站队。他几乎是，两党支持的，两党支持的。你觉得呢？以下是你关于——我们以前用过“两党支持”这个词，顺便说一句。所以这就是我说的。我说我们以前用过它。相当蹩脚的落地动作。相当蹩脚的落地动作。我们会在下一集播客中补偿你的。听众朋友。哦，谢天你刚刚挽救了它。你刚刚挽救了它。你他妈的混蛋。请
stand by. Yeah, Rob with one. Please stand by. Please stand by. Smart. Smart is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjurf. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
稍候。是的，罗伯，带一个。请稍候。请稍候。“Smart”是100%有机且手工精制的，由贝内特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞和罗伯·阿姆朱夫制作。“Smart Loss”。我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或Wondry应用来提前收听无广告版。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。